haha
it doesn't smell terrible but looks
weird as hell it definitely smells kind
of coleslaw II oh it's like fish with
purple mayonnaise on top tastes like the
ocean a minimus
it has a very like dirt like aftertaste
which you know I like dirt I ate dirt
growing up the Russians go to space I
wonder if they make the astronauts eat -
smells normal smells Vilonia SH this is
this is the color of the zombies on the
walking dead I've never had a ballooning
mm-hm
that's baloney I'd say this tastes like
purchasing a Dell computer just no joy
doesn't taste like anything I actually
like it to be honest Natasha I have a
long yeah no only if you give me your
fish covered in beets
uh-oh oh that's so pickled now this is
tough this is so hard way thanks mmm
what a flavor Wow
the garlic eNOS of it helps me get
through it all this tastes like similar
to acid on my grandmother like I would
blend that and drink it so much you're
wrong the meat smells good but what why
I don't know if I can do this mm-hmm
like the taste is fine does it taste
like you know chicken pot pie whatever
it's the texture oh my god this is so
gross you brought us hetra spot you also
brought us this so it's what kind of
back at zero this is what you would eat
at the capital is a hunger game
it's a rock big fat what this is really
really weird I'm not getting any smell
at all right must you do this to me this
is already going horribly long so Tom
it's still salted are you gonna kill me
I think I'm into it if I have to choose
between the meat jello and this I would
take like 20 of these cars meat related
items this might be the better baby I
would say this is probably the best
thing that we've had today thumbs up A+
more pickled tomatoes we need more bit
pickled tomatoes in our lives we really
do we get more creative with our
pickling in general I don't know why we
don't pickle everything I love pickling